in this video we're going to figure out
what the sine
cosine
and tangent of two very important angles
are angles that you'll see a lot in your
trigonometric and just in general in
your regular life so these are the
angles pi over 3 radians and pi over 6
radians and sometimes it's useful to
visualize them as degrees pi over 3 you
might remember pi radians is 180 degrees
so you divide that by 3 this is
equivalent to 60 degrees and once again
180 degrees which is the same thing as
pi radians divided by 6 is the same
thing as 30 degrees
now i'm going to do it using the unit
circle definition of trig functions but
to help us there i'm going to give us a
little bit of a reminder of what some of
you might be familiar with as 30 60 90
triangles which i guess we could also
call pi over 6 pi over 3 pi over 2
triangles and so let me just draw one
because this is going to be really
helpful in establishing these trig
functions using the unit circle
definition
so let me draw a triangle here it's hand
drawn so it's not as neat as it could be
so this right over here is a right angle
and let's say that this one is pi over
3 radians which is the same thing as 60
degrees and this one over here is pi
over 6 radians which is the same thing
as 30 degrees
now let's also say that the longest side
the hypotenuse here has length one
now to help us think about what the
other two sides are what i'm going to do
is flip this triangle over this side
right over here and essentially
construct a mirror image
so because this right over here is a
mirror image we immediately know a few
things we know that this length right
over here is going to be congruent to
this length over here
and let me actually finish drawing the
entire triangle
it's going to look something like this
and since it's once again it's a
reflection this length over here is
going to have length 1
this is going to be pi
over 6 radians this is going to be pi
over 3 radians
so what else do we know about this
larger triangle now
well we know it's an equilateral
triangle all the angles pi over 3
radians pi over 3 radians and if you add
2 pi over 6's together you're going to
get pi over 3 as well so it's a 60
degree 60 degree 60 degree triangle and
so all the sides are going to have the
same length it's going to be one one and
one and if these two sides are congruent
of the smaller triangles or the smaller
right triangles well then this right
over here must be one half and then this
right over here must be one half as well
now that's going to be useful for
figuring out what this length right over
here is going to be
because we have two right triangles we
could use either one but if we just use
this bottom right triangle here the
pythagorean theorem tells us that one
half squared let's call this b so plus b
squared i'm just pattern matching a
squared plus b squared is equal to c
squared where c is the length of the
hypotenuse
is equal to 1 squared
and so we get that 1 4
plus b squared is equal to 1 or
subtracting 1 4 from both sides b
squared is equal to 3 4 and then taking
the principal root of both sides we get
b is equal to the square root of 3
over 2.
so just like that we have figured out
what all the lengths of this 30 60 90
triangle are so b here is equal to
square root of 3 over 2. now i said this
would be useful as we go into the unit
circle definitions of sine cosine and
tangent and we're about to see why so
here i have two different unit circles
i'm going to use one for each of these
angles so first let's think about pi
over 3 radians and so pi over 3
would look something like
this
so this is pi
over 3 radians
and the cosine and sine can be
determined by the x and y coordinates of
this point where this radius intersects
the actual unit circle the coordinates
here are going to be cosine
of pi over 3 radians and sine of pi over
3 radians
or another way to think about it is i
can set up a 30-60-90 triangle here so
i'm going to drop a perpendicular
this is this would be 90 degrees or pi
over 2 radians and then this angle over
here if this is 60 this is 90 this is
going to be 30 or another way of
thinking about it's going to be pi
over 6 radians it's going to be just
like one of these triangles here
and so the x coordinate which is going
to be the same thing as the cosine of pi
over 3 is going to be the length of this
side right over here well what's that
going to be well when your hypotenuse is
1 we know that the shorter side the side
opposite the pi over 6 radians is
one-half so just like that we have been
able to establish that cosine of pi over
three radians is equal to one-half this
right over here is one-half that is the
x-coordinate where this radius
intersects the unit circle
now what about the y
coordinate what is sine of pi over 3
going to be
well the y coordinate is the same thing
as the length of this side
and once again it goes back to being
this triangle if this is one this is one
half this is one this is one half this
other side is going to be square root of
3 over 2. so sine of pi over 3 is going
to be square root of 3 over 2. so let me
write that down sine
of pi over 3 is equal to square root of
3 over 2. and these are good ones to
know i never say really memorize things
it's always good to know how to derive
things in case you forget
but if you had to memorize some i would
highly recommend memorizing these and
then of course from these we can figure
out the tangent the tangent is just
going to be the sine over the cosine so
let me write it down here the tangent
of pi
over 3 is going to be the sine which is
square root of 3 over two
over the cosine which is one half got a
little scrunchy down there and so this
is just going to be square root of three
over two times two is just going to be
square root of three
so now let's just use that same logic
for pi over six and in fact i encourage
you to pause this video and see if you
can do that on your own
all right now let's draw a radius that
forms a pi over six
radian angle with a positive x-axis
might look like that so if that's going
to be pi over 6 radians you might
imagine
it's interesting to drop a perpendicular
here
and see what type of triangle we've
constructed so this has length 1 this is
pi over 6 radians this is a right angle
so this again is going to follow the
same pattern this will be pi
over
3 radians and so the sides are exactly
the exact same as this top blue triangle
here
so we know that this length over here is
going to be one-half
we know that this length over here
is going to be square root of three
over two and that's useful because that
tells us the coordinates here the
coordinates here the x-coordinate of
this point where the radius intersects
the unit circle is square root of three
over two and then the y-coordinate is
one-half and that immediately tells us
the cosine and the sine of pi over 6.
let's just write it down so this tells
us that cosine
of pi
over 6 is equal to square root of 3 over
2
and sine
of pi over 6
is equal to one-half notice we just
actually just swapped these two things
around because now the angle that we're
taking the sine or cosine of is a
different angle on a 30-60-90 triangle
but we're essentially utilizing the same
side measures is one way to think about
it and then what's the tangent going to
be i'll write it down here the tangent
of pi
over 6 is going to be the sine
over the cosine square root of 3 over 2
and so that's going to be equal to
one-half times 2 over the square root of
3 which is equal to 1 over the square
root of 3. now some people sometimes
don't like radicals in the denominator
and so you could multiply the numerator
and the denominator by square root of
three if you like to get something like
this you multiply the numerator and
denominator by square root of three you
get square root of three over three
which is another way of writing tangent
of pi over six
but either way we're done it's very
useful to know the cosine sine and
tangent of both pi over three and pi
over six and now you also know how to
derive it